one last point before we go and you know
we're we could talk about
this issue i think for a full two hours
if we wanted to
carson wentz avoided talking to the
media yesterday and this is a different
twist on all of this because
carson wentz has been the subject of
reporting that he wants out of
philadelphia
and chris morton espn reported on sunday
that the relationship between carson
wentz and doug peterson is fractured
beyond repair
that clearly is not coming from the
eagles that's coming from wence or his
agents and it's so
strong of a report that if it's false
carson wentz needs to say it's false and
the fact that carson wentz declined to
talk to reporters yesterday
does not sit well with me for a couple
of reasons first of all
you've got this impression out there
that the relationship between
wentz and peterson is broken beyond
repair you need to say whether or not
that you need to address that one way or
the other either these reports are false
or they're true either you want to stay
or you want to go
but when you're the franchise
quarterback of an nfl team
silence in a situation like this to me
isn't an option chris
i think it was incumbent on him to say
something if you're going to
duck talking to the media in a setting
like this
maybe i i i want to choose my words very
carefully here because we
heard the reports all year long that he
was he was shaken from a confident
standpoint by the arrival of jalen hurts
and you know is that something that's
contributed to his play
i just think if you can't stand up and
answer questions when you are kind of at
the center of this
it makes me wonder are you the right guy
to lead a team like the eagles at the
quarterback position is that wrong for
me to think
i don't think it is listen if there's
one flaw i think with carson wentz is he
has not embraced the philadelphia way
like you know hey they're in your that's
an in-your-face
group of people don't be afraid to be
in your face back make yourself open let
yourself be
seen show your emotions that's the thing
we've seen carson wentz has issues with
you know there's obviously an issue with
him in the locker room we've heard that
over the last two years
about his ability to communicate there
and i don't think
he's put forth you know the greatest
look for himself
in front of the philadelphia fans always
either uh you know when he's sitting at
the podium
and doing all that i i agree with you
that i think
would have been best for carson wentz is
to talk yesterday
and take some of the you know questions
head on and do your best to
diplomatically answer them without
throwing anybody under the bus
but i think the biggest thing i take
away from that more than anything
you know right or wrong it just tells me
that wence wants
out wence doesn't want to be there he
doesn't want to have to answer that
question because maybe he feels like he
can't give his honest answer
either way like we've talked about i
think it's best for carson wentz to move
on if i was advising him
there's a no-win situation in
philadelphia get out
and i think he is bothered by the whole
situation i don't doubt whether he can
handle pressure i think he is fine with
that
you know i wish he would be a little
different in that way but damn he did
play with nick foles sitting there
breathing over his back as the super
bowl
mvp and all that type of stuff but
either way it just feels like it's kind
of come to an end there and
i don't think carson wentz is in a good
situation staying in philadelphia
i just think if he wants out at some
point he needs to say so playing these
games behind the scenes having leaks to
reporters and trying to build your case
that way
that is not going to be effective in in
leaving philadelphia the right way and
arriving in a new agreement right way
and i don't know what the answer is i'm
not suggesting he should get on his
treadmill in the middle of the night and
shoot a video where he refers to himself
as mr big chest like antonio brown
a couple of years ago when he went on an
absolute
spree to try to get out of pittsburgh
and it was one video after another one
tactic after another that's way too much
but at some point
shut down with somebody do a video say
what you want
speak from the heart if you want out
these whispers to reporters
i don't think are good enough and then
silence when there's an opportunity to
talk when there are obvious questions
that's not good either hi i'm mike
tarico and thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports